il est 5 heures du matin
l'avancée dans les bars
couvert de but
j'avais mon fusil dans les mains à face
euros prenaient au loin
de l'altitude
les chiens pressé
marchait devant
dans les roseaux
[Musique]
par-dessus des temps
danger
passé l'espace aura
[Musique]
cette année
c'est trop
par-dessus et chant
ota
là
agen
la forêt enchantée
le soleil m
vous
à
je
avec mon fusil dans les mains
fond de moi je me sentais
[Musique]
coupable
alors je suis parti tout seul
j'emmenais mon épingle
en promenade
[Musique]
je regardais
plus le du ciel
et j'étais
[Musique]
par-dessus les temps soudain j'ai
soit sauvage
la méditerranée
votre amour
[Musique]
à
elles ont les l'ua
je
la forêt chante
elle aime le soleil
m
[Musique]
tous ces mois
là haut
duras
moi
j'aurais bien
[Musique]
et
sa compagne
auj
[Musique]
aia
plus de seize mois
j'ai eu m 6
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]